Hey,
how are you?
How are you everybody?
It's bill bar.
Just check it
here on a Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday for the Monday morning podcast on a Thursday,
just before Friday during the Thursday afternoon that I'm actually recording on
a Wednesday,
um,
appear in Chattanooga,
Chattanooga.
Um,
on our way up to Lexington,
Lexington,
Kentucky and a continuing along this long journey through the south,
through the fucking south.
I was your last couple of days,
but yeah.
Did you go to the gym?
Do eat some fucking frosting.
Did you hate yourself afterwards?
I hate myself.
I hate what I do that do you know,
last night I went over to an intimate cake,
not two,
not three,
four fingers swiped across the stop top of it and stuck it in my mouth.
You ever see a baby eat how they stick their whole hand in their mouth?
I was doing that
and it was like,
why am I doing this?
The next thing you know,
I had the frosting,
I was losing my hair with it.
I was a Meth,
but I woke up the next day and there was a song in my head.
I go to the gym everyday,
it just become popping up.
Um,
I've actually been doing all right,
but I've been eating like an asshole today,
today,
like an asshole.
We,
uh,
picked up a law heads dad along the way out in Alabama and we stopped.
Uh,
they made us a homemade meal a lot.
His mom medicine,
these homemade meal of bras and right down the street,
you know,
what was one of those,
a barbecue places.
My favorite barbecue place in all of Alabama is a sauce.
Barbecue stands for smart ass Wilsons and they got this white barbecue sauce
that they put on the chicken and it's just,
it's fucking amazing.
And of course I had to get that too.
So we got that.
We got on the bus and we're like,
well wait,
wait.
We have for dinner we had for dinner.
And we just kept smelling it and we were like,
all right,
fuck it.
All right.
Hey Dad stuff.
It was delicious.
Couple of Miller high life and,
um,
I know you go,
I just gave away like five days at the gym.
What a fucking dope.
Huh?
Do you know what his life to walk the earth as a freckle dope?
I do.
And it's all gonna be in Mike Book that comes out never.
Um,
anyways,
let's,
let's get on it.
It just make a noise.
I'd let less debt.
Let's get on the fucking,
uh,
you know,
if you knew what the,
the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcasts,
you know,
I just check in on you.
I do a little half hour thing just to get your view a little hump days here,
right?
You pay days.
You know,
I've been saying that you guys get paid on Thursday.
That's how it was back when I had a job,
when I had a real fucking job.
You know,
and I guess you guys get paid on Friday now and God knows the women don't make
as much as the men.
Um,
and men don't care.
Why would they?
They're winning in that scenario.
Sorry.
I think it's a tragedy.
I think it's a tragedy that when you know you,
you're down at the subway sandwich store and you take out fucking five slices of
that process,
gray meat and put it on a God damn piece of bread.
You don't make the same amount of money that is out rages.
And uh,
good luck to you guys trying to turn that around because,
uh,
I got my own problems.
I'll do what everybody else does.
I'll be,
I god add his own right and then I'll just get on with my life.
Like all those douchebags who stood up during Oscar night when,
uh,
the chick from fucking true romance said whatever she said,
then everybody stood up and applauded and then everything remained the same.
They went right back to it.
You know,
isn't that what always happens?
We needed to clean up the rivers and everybody hip that Bra and nobody sits down
promptly,
goes upside takes off this suspenders.
And what do they do?
They take a dump right in the river.
It's how it works.
Anybody's a good shit when the TV cameras aren't.
Um,
all right,
so here's the deal.
If you want them to just have me go off on some shit,
you know,
you just,
just a Hashtag,
uh,
the MMP,
no,
that's not what you want to do.
I am the fucking worst.
Don't listen to me here.
You hashtag t a m m p.
That's it.
I finally got it.
Send it to at the m m podcast and then Hashtag t a m m p tango.
Alpha Mike,
Mike,
Papa.
All right,
there you go.
That's what I need you to do.
And then I'll just go off on shit.
And uh,
as always,
let's check in.
Let's,
what I'll do on Thursdays.
Look into,
let's check in on the world of nothing.
What's going on this week.
All right?
Evidently Bud light.
You know,
they got that fucking thing where they,
uh,
somebody just comes in and they're like,
are you up for anything?
And the guy's like,
Holy Shit,
you're that guy from that thing.
And next thing you know,
he's at a concert and then he's shooting pool with the captain Kirk,
or whatever the fuck happens for the most,
Bro.
Tastic fucking evening of their lives.
Run for your wife's right.
It's the greatest night of your fucking life,
thanks to bud light.
So they for some reason on their,
on their beer bottle,
put uh,
the perfect beer for removing no from your vocabulary for the night.
Hashtag up for whatever.
Now how they didn't realize that this was just going to get the clamp culture
all fucking stir it up right there.
I mean it's fucking over.
And they flipped out and they were just like,
oh thanks a lot bud light.
Thank you for promoting
rape culture.
You know,
and they're all sitting there.
Oh No.
We were trying to get a,
we would try to get people to buy our boots.
We were not trying to advocate rape.
I love other,
did they really think that?
That that's what they were doing here.
These women think it capital letters.
This is an okay.
Uh,
no means no.
This ad perpetuates rape culture and we're hashtag not buying it.
I like how women are acting like they buy bud light.
What was the last time you saw a woman going to buy a fucking 12 pack of Bud
Light?
Bud light is for middle aged white dudes who were buttoned down shirts and a
coming out the side of them.
Right.
And they just ate a fucking broad and now they're trying to lighten up the real
shit.
I'm talking about me.
Um,
what else we got here?
A Bud light sweetheart.
Look,
people are criticizing bud light's new tagline,
claiming that it promotes rape culture.
Uh,
this is not a good slogan.
I know that you want us to have fun but say yes to life.
I don't know.
It's one of these things that people get flipping out.
They're obviously not advocating rape,
but I mean,
how the fuck do you know with w w when you're making booze,
how do you not see this shit storm coming?
I'm actually going side.
I'm not going to say bud lights fucking morons for not seeing that shit storm
coming.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
at this point,
if,
uh,
if you leave the microwave door ajar in your home,
you're somehow advocating rape culture suggesting that women's legs like the,
the,
the microwave door should also be a jar,
right?
Are you?
I don't know what all I know is it's a very strange climate.
Little all those fucking words that they use.
Um,
all right.
What else do we got here?
Hey Bill,
you've got to talk about this story.
Not enough room to explain.
Uh,
just more women needing apologies.
Why don't more women right into this?
Why do you guys just listen to me and go,
this guy's a cave man.
I don't want to listen to them.
Can we fuck it?
Balances out a perfume from dead people?
Well,
how do you not click on this perfume from dead Chevelle?
Okay.
Company makes perfume that smells like deceased loved ones.
This isn't real.
Yeah.
Does anything smell grosser than your fucking grandparents?
Right before they die,
they vote.
The decomposition is already,
it's already begun.
Right?
Having Sake,
are you guys having trouble saying goodbye to a loved one who passed away and
you're just bottling up your emotions,
bottled up their scent in perfume and perfume for for 600.
Buck Buck's Sean Dowling has more TV and more details on this wacky story.
I'll give me a fucking break.
Jesus Christ.
Let it go,
dude.
That is so fucking creepy.
It's funny when you're talking about grandparents.
Everything else that's fucking creepy.
That's like some serial killer shit.
You want like a fucking trophy?
Um,
all right.
This is,
this is rough.
Do we already got dead people and rape already?
I this,
this is the direction I want to go to,
right?
All right.
Best the guy you've ever had and was it,
uh,
was it the cigar?
Okay.
You know what?
I'm really figuring out with all this shit.
This is just involving me having to read out loud even more.
Um,
all right,
we are collecting outrage was Duh,
Duh,
Duh.
Let me scroll.
Oh wait,
Mcdonald's.
Hey,
did you guys see Mcdonald's is closing some,
uh,
Mcdonald's had to start closing some stores.
Did I already talk about this?
I can't fucking remember.
I was talking the other day how our food supplies basically become poison.
And I got a couple of people sending me,
hey bill care to send me some links to some of your research.
It did.
I understand I'm worthy of that criticism.
But also if you're really going to sit there and try to tell me that I'm at not
at least half right on how fucked up our food supply is right now.
All right,
I'll give you this right now.
Here's my,
I'll cite this source.
When I was a kid,
a chicken was like maybe one or two weight classes above a fucking pit pigeon.
And I'm not talking about a Cornish hen.
Alright,
some little fucking partridge.
I'm,
I'm talking about a full size adult chicken that lived a whole life,
accomplished his dreams before it got its head fucking lopped off.
Now like chickens look like Mark McGuire in 1998 they're fucking gigantic.
They're like Turkey Juniors.
So like what,
what are the chickens doing now?
Aren't they hitting the gym?
Sorry.
Um,
to doing depth drinking some protein shakes.
Give me a fucking break.
I don't trust anything and that does not make me somebody with a tin foil hat
on.
It makes me fucking smart.
I love how the,
the,
the cigarette people for years sat there and they were like,
I don't think nicotine is addictive.
Then they passed.
And another guy,
I do not think nicotine is addictive.
When I sat each pick a date,
is that a thing?
They all knew it was.
They didn't give a fuck.
All right.
But that's what they hitched their wagons to.
So they continued to lie.
He look at the fucking bankers that lie at that level.
Everybody lies at that fucking La.
Everybody lies in general,
right?
Forget about when there's a bunch of money whores and power involved,
Food is no different.
Why would you trust those cuts?
You know,
I don't know.
But you know what?
Go ahead and do it.
Have at it for as much as I sit here and Bitch Moan and complain about it,
I actually tried to eat like totally a farmer's market.
All of that stuff.
It was practically impossible.
First of all,
you go down in the farmer's markets and the big farms,
they're already in there and they just can legally have like,
you know,
they're fucking products called,
uh,
you know,
home grown Eddie's,
and that's just the name of some giant corporation that's got,
you know,
God knows what and they're fucking food.
Right.
And when I actually went to this farmer's market,
I was like,
I wanted to buy a chicken that it was just a fucking chicken.
Right.
I didn't want to buy a,
who's that guy who fucking ran that race and beat Carl Lewis,
the Ben Johnson.
I didn't want the Ben Johnson fucking a chicken,
you know,
and this guy had all these things they all say,
and the organic also their own natural.
And I pointed each one of them.
I forgot the question I was supposed to ask.
I learned it in this documentary and ass and the guy shook his head no,
once the next one shook his head.
No.
I said,
where is one that just was a fucking chicken and eight what chickens ate in the
1920s.
And he goes all the way down there.
And I looked at it and I was like,
that's a fucking chicken.
And he goes,
yeah,
that's what they look like when you don't fucking,
when they don't have the same workout program is Lal.
Elsedo right.
So whatever,
don't listen to me.
Don't give a fuck.
Laugh at me.
Think I'm a fucking moron.
But just realize you're not a fucking scientist either.
Okay.
I don't believe anything.
When I was watching those Baltimore riots and they came up with that,
we in credible sources that the gangs,
you have all gone,
uh,
called each other up and have decided to attack the police as one collective
unit.
I mean,
did you actually sit there and go,
oh my God,
am I watching warriors or is this really happening?
Uh,
that reeked of a horse shit.
Either somebody just made that up.
Or if I'm on the cop side,
I'm going like,
look,
we've got to crack some skulls here to get this fucking thing under control,
but God knows they're going to be filming all of this and we're going to have
even more problems.
So,
uh,
let's try to get out in front of this thing.
Anybody got any ideas?
Uh,
you there in the back?
Oh,
what if we say,
uh,
there's a black zombies and uh,
they got a bulla and their teeth.
All right.
That's,
you know,
it's a little out there,
but yeah,
you're on the right track.
What are you already got the fucking,
uh,
McMurtry.
All right,
finally somebody goes,
what have you just say the gangs,
the gangs,
all organized
site.
Incredible.
Falafels um,
Jesus Christ.
What a shit show.
It was that deep.
Was that deep enough for you might take on Baltimore.
Jesus Christ.
What a shit show says bill burr enough said topic over Ryan ended.
You know,
if they just had me say that from a hot air balloon,
so I seem neutral.
All right.
And I just yelled at through a bull horn down at the people by just yelled down,
crying.
What a shit show.
It would be over,
you know,
and they won't let me,
you know why?
Because the government want it.
Sorry.
All right,
let's get to some more of this shit here.
Um,
where am I going here?
I like acting like a fucking moron on this because it makes people feel smart.
Right?
You guys all get the fucking give me shit.
Gi Bill.
I thought I was fucking dumb,
but x,
Y and Z.
Go fuck yourself.
You just as stupid as I am.
All right bill,
why do you think Tim Teebo still gets chances to play in the league?
Is Jesus really looking out for him?
Um,
I think cause he sells a ton of fucking jerseys.
He's a star,
uh,
without the statue.
He's a status star,
but he's got all that other stuff and uh,
you know,
come on man.
There's not nothing sells fucking jerseys across America.
Like a white guy that plays sports.
That's a virgin.
That's into Jesus.
I mean that's,
it's fucking over marketing teams that just jerking off.
It's just,
it's,
he did the,
I guess that's what,
I guess that's why it would be,
but I would just think that the,
the Patriots sign them cause they were trying to get Aaron Hernandez under
control.
And I guess,
you know,
I don't know.
The rumor was that when they both played at Florida that Tim Teebo would,
uh,
would,
I don't know,
he would like sing some Christian songs to Aaron Hernandez before games.
So he,
you know,
keep in mind that Jesus Christ has died for us.
Hey Aaron,
don't shoot anybody.
We're playing South Carolina.
Keep your head on a swivel.
Um,
you know what I'm gonna do tonight?
Cause I'm actually going to root for the fucking,
uh,
I got a roof for Tampa Bay to beat Detroit even though I like original six teams
because they've,
they fucking own the Canadians.
That's all I'm doing here.
I'm just rooting against the Canadians.
It's a very negative year for me.
You know what I make is my team didn't make it so now just as fucking sad sack,
bitter cont sitting on the right in the fucking front row,
frosting up the glass,
just hoping they're going to fucking lose.
Actually,
I've been touring so much admin time to watch anything.
Um,
I know there was some big hit in the last game that got uh,
uh,
a Detroit guy suspended.
I guess he came up off his skates is what I'm guessing you can't get mad at him
cause it was a fucking head shot.
The guy was bent over at the waist.
I mean,
what are you supposed to do?
Um,
I dunno.
I have no idea.
But I will be rooting for Tampa Bay and uh,
hopefully they'll fucking win and then immediately I'll start rooting against
them because the Stanley Cup should not be in Florida ever.
It just shouldn't be.
You don't deserve it.
First of all,
to me that ice,
I don't know if you guys and all that down to Florida,
it's going to melt.
Okay.
Just keep that in mind.
Um,
anyways,
what else do I got here?
Uh,
Bill,
check this out to see how crazy smart crows are.
There has to be some gold here.
Crows.
A smart,
well,
I guess we know what kind of bird I wouldn't be
animal.
What the fuck is wrong with people?
Animal.
I came to say cognition.
Crows understand water displacement.
Oh,
I've seen this
cro keeps putting what up,
putting rocks in a cylinder to make the water come up so it can finally take a
sip out of it.
Okay.
Evidently this is amazing.
Have they tried this with the other birds or is it just this one?
Does a seagull just sit there and be like,
I can't fucking Drake it man.
Um,
Jesus Christ,
this looks like a fucking science test.
I flunked.
All right.
I've had enough of these fucking hashtag things so well do when it's making me
feel dumb.
Feeling like a Goddamn dope.
Um,
all right.
So we got,
we've done nine out of 11,
ladies and gentlemen,
nine out of 11 stops on the Billy Bible belter and it's been amazing.
We were in Mobile Ama,
Alabama,
uh,
last night and I would stop mobile.
Uh,
was um,
an English name.
You know,
I thought English settlers came up with that.
I had to realize that it was a French colony and it was actually a French word.
And uh,
I dunno,
they lost some fucking war next to know the English had it and then the Spanish
had it.
And then we had,
it had no idea.
The only thing I knew about mobile,
Alabama was Ken Burns the war and,
uh,
some Martin Luther King thing,
I don't know if he got,
took a rock to the head or something like that.
I was at that March.
We had the white shirt and he was bleeding and he had the fucking handkerchief.
Everybody had handkerchiefs back then.
Just how classy people dressed.
Like al was.
Martin Luther King when he died,
he's probably like 10 years younger than me.
Maybe because he like 38,
39,
maybe 40.
Just the way everybody dressed,
walking around shirt and tie suit.
Yeah.
Fucking handkerchief.
Nobody dresses like that anymore.
Everybody look at me.
I dress like,
I believe I'm sitting here right now.
I go to and sweat pants and a tee shirt.
I could go to church like this,
you know,
people will,
some people,
older people would frown upon it,
but it'd be,
it'd be considered.
Okay.
Um,
I'm actually considering dressing up for the,
uh,
yeah,
the Lexington,
Kentucky show.
My,
where my,
where my derby outfit,
but I don't know if I can fucking handle having that God sport coat on for my
entire show.
You know,
I think sport coats if for people that know how to write jokes,
but guys like mate,
you know where it's a lot of cursing and silly faces.
I mean,
I got a flail the arms around,
right.
Anyways,
I've been,
uh,
last night's show and mobile might've been that one in the Memphis one.
New Orleans was great.
Just was like a,
they were all great.
Knoxville,
you don't chat a Nigga.
When we played that place,
I didn't realize that it was an old hockey rink.
I had no idea it should be such an amazing tour.
But uh,
I'm not as young as I used to be.
People.
Well,
who's kidding?
Who?
Nobody is you dumb.
Fuck is somebody young,
younger than they used to be?
Um,
I'm feeling my age on this one to two weeks out is a long goddamn time,
right?
I can't fucking handle this shit anymore.
I'm going to have to,
I'm going to do like fucking week long tours.
That's what I'm going to do.
And we wear slippers and come out on stage.
You know,
last night they actually had a little area rug down there and my,
or for some reason says I need two stools.
I guess one is if I want to sit down the other ones for the fucking bottled
water.
And I've been telling my agent for the longest time we got to take that out
there.
I don't,
I don't need two stools who might do some couple of dips out there.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
but last night I went out there and they had two chairs and a table in the
middle with the water on it with the tablecloth and it felt like I was doing a
little play and it actually really affected my standup and I was doing all these
little,
like I immediately just acted like I was interviewing myself on some lifetime
achievement thing and um,
like three or four times during my act,
it just made my bits go in different directions and just shit that I've been
enjoying doing,
which is just doing a character.
We only hear one side of the conversation and all of that.
And uh,
it really enhanced that.
So now after all this time of saying I didn't want the two stools,
I might now go,
I like two chairs with a table,
tablecloth and little area rug,
you know.
And I saw Cosby pre rape allegations.
He had a set up like that.
He had a,
he had a little area rug,
he had a chair and he had a,
he had a table.
I liked the extra chair cause the extra chair makes it feel,
you can pretend like there's somebody there talking,
you know,
like I've been doing this stupid bit about how uh,
Bruce Jenner,
you know,
God bless him and everything he wants to do.
I don't have a fucking problem with that.
But the fact that it's a national news and a,
there was just something about sitting there pretending to read the news and
talking about whether or not Bruce was or was not going to keep his dick as
national news.
Meanwhile,
like,
you know,
baby seals are Washington up onto the fucking shorts.
Nobody gives a fuck.
Right?
Nobody talks about it anyways.
Um,
I don't know.
I think that might be my new setup.
You know,
my new thing in my fucking ride.
Um,
anyways,
I don't even know what happens is the last time I talked to you guys,
I'm so fucking out of it.
Did the uh,
did the jam band Guy Fucking Yank the other guy's arm out of his socket?
You see that filthy play?
Oh,
I talked about that.
I actually talked about,
that's right.
I talked about that already.
Um,
but anyways,
who do you like?
You know what?
I'm such a fucking moron.
When I was sitting at trash and the clippers,
I was saying the blues are like the,
like the clippers on ice where they just never get out of the first round.
I had no idea that the clippers won game three at that point.
They were,
they have to one or is it two to all I know.
Is they going to like,
uh,
what was it?
Game six now spur spowers bars one last two where they're up flood three games
to two.
I fucking hate that.
I know what's going on in hope.
And I don't know what's going on in hockey is cause I'm fucking traveling with
Verdesian Lawhead and they're uh,
you know,
they're big time fucking hoop guys.
And um,
you know,
I'm not going to be a cunt.
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna play the headliner card in San.
Hey guys,
come on.
Who's kidding?
Who,
who's telling the most shit jokes tonight?
Meet?
Uh,
you exactly.
Oh God dammit.
Give up the fucking television.
I am tonight.
I am going to watch that game seven.
I'm a watch that game seven.
It's probably gonna come on here in a few minutes.
Um,
like I said,
I am recording this on Wednesday.
So,
uh,
I guess as you listen to this,
you,
I know who wants.
So bill,
why don't you give us your predictions?
You have to tell you what,
I'll give you my prediction for,
uh,
for game seven,
Detroit,
Tampa,
and I'll give you the Pacquiao.
Mayweather.
All right.
I think Detroit wince,
I dunno why they went,
the best defenseman is out.
I still think they fucking win because,
uh,
because there Detroit and cause they got a great group of youngsters,
they always seem to know like who the next fucking dat suit guy is.
They always seem to get him Berlin's we never get them.
We get those hard working guys,
those blue collar guys going into the corners.
Um,
and I just think that they're going to step up.
I'm assuming it's a home game for Detroit.
I'm assuming it's in Detroit.
That's if it's in Detroit.
I think that they went and even it's in Florida,
I still think they lose because it's Florida and it's hockey and that's how it
goes.
So I'm picking Detroit and game seven,
I picking this spurs to finish off the clippers in game six,
even though it's going to be back home.
Right.
It does go back home.
I'll fucking though.
And then,
uh,
Mayweather.
This is what I think's going to happen.
Packy I was going to come out and he basically has about three and a half
fucking rounds to knock Mayweather on his ass before Mayweather figures out what
the fuck.
You know,
he just basically has packy I was entire style figured out and then he keeps,
he's just the elusive for the rest of the fight and wins a split decision on
points.
That's what I,
I think he survived whatever pack.
Yeah,
I was going to do.
And uh,
I think he wins on points and I think fans will be disappointed as they always
are because nobody got knocked out.
The beauty was fucking lame.
Um,
that's what I think.
I think that some might even be more upset than a skin tag nation was when they
showed it.
Was it Jared Leto,
Jared,
Jerry,
Larry.
I don't know what his fucking name is.
That guy from Dallas buyers club at won,
won,
won an Oscar and also was in a successful,
right.
He walks around with a,
that James Taylor looked at,
singer songwriter.
I've seen fire and I've seen rain now saying sunny days.
And I thought,
[inaudible] man,
I fucking hate that song.
It's like,
hey dude,
you know,
I'm sorry your friend died but mine didn't.
So why don't you fucking pick up the tempo and put a little sunshine in your
music or very least let us know that you're going to sing about your dead
friend.
But I stopped.
I'd CEO one more time.
Jesus,
what's his name?
James Taylor.
Jesus Christ.
Whenever I see they could James Taylor,
whenever he's singing,
all I do is picture Hillary and Bill Clinton in the balcony standing up dancing
really bad.
That's all I think of when I hear his music.
I'm sorry.
I think of that and I picture James Taylor and rollerblades before the concert.
You know,
they did a whole story on him one time and they had them roller blading.
He said,
I love it.
I can't stop,
can't stop rollerblading.
I really enjoy it.
He embraced it that granted,
this is when,
when it was through the fucking roof,
rollerblading was the shit.
I enjoyed it.
Play rollerblade hockey get own to me.
And I gotta tell you after a long day's work,
putting on a pair of boy shorts and,
and skating down the street,
I thought it was,
I thought it was very refreshing.
You know,
I can only imagine if I had a pair of me undies.
I want to apologize to all of you for putting that image in your got damn heads.
Um,
so anyways,
all these comic book Nerds,
right?
Comic Con fucking people flipped out,
flipped out when they saw the new one said he looked like he was from hot topic
and all that type of shit.
Let me,
can I ask you guys,
you know,
I always trash the comic book people because I'm not into it.
So obviously it's gotta be stupid if it didn't appeal to me,
right?
There's an enlightened way to go through life.
I don't like that.
That must be stupid.
Um,
why do you guys get so God damn upset all the time?
You know,
like,
has there ever been a time where they revealed,
you know what the new Bat Bat jet ski was going to look like?
That you actually thought it looked good?
You didn't think it looked lame,
you know the sweat under your man tits didn't start to grow.
Why do you guys always Keno?
I don't have they ever picked anybody to pick baton to play Batman that you
liked?
Who was a good Batman?
Was Adam West?
That can't be shit.
I actually liked that shelf.
Ben and Eh,
um,
sorry.
Um,
Michael Keaton.
I didn't like Michael Keaton when he played Batman.
I like him now.
I like him as an old curmudgeonly guy.
Okay.
When he said,
you know,
yeah,
what is he saying?
That movie?
He says,
that's right ice man.
I am
Batman.
And then he goes,
he chomps down on his teeth,
right?
And then they played volleyball and he had to keep his mask on band aid,
Dank,
Dank.
Dang it.
Dang name.
Nanny defeated the Russians and he was in the back plane upside down.
And then Robin,
Robin Watch out for the canopy,
you know.
Then Meg Ryan cried cause Robin died.
Was that Burt Ward Jr?
I don't fucking remember why you guys always upset.
Like who?
Who Do you think should play Batman?
What's wrong with Ben Affleck?
He's got the perfect job to have like most of his face covered by a mask,
you know,
you know to be a good Batman.
Jay Leno,
Jay Leno has got a great job.
Ben Affleck,
Woody Harrelson,
the way he's making his John True detective.
Would you like any of those guys or would that get y'all,
aren't you,
aren't you cartoon Comic Book Reading People and you just mad that they didn't
pick you?
Is that what it really comes down to?
Nothing can live up to what you've built it up to be.
Oh God,
it's such a cunt.
Why do I do,
why can't I just let people enjoy shit anyways?
Well they go this year,
there's a little podcast for the week.
I'm sitting here doing my laundry.
This is life on the road.
The most exciting part of my day was there was a washer and dryer one.
Like I have the hotel room right at the very end and right around the corner
there's a washer and a dryer.
And I am so psyched that I'm washing my socks and me undies,
me undies,
no fucking dirty shit in my luggage.
I hate dirty.
I dirty laundry in the luggage.
Skeeves me out.
And whenever I've,
I,
I'm on the road like this,
I always make sure like right before,
like this tour and Saturday,
right?
Say,
um,
I'm knocking it out.
So whatever,
I have like two days,
two days where that's acceptable as far as he says,
unacceptable as far as diversity effect podcast says on the all things comedy
network,
uh,
a week's worth of fucking laundry in your bag and you're shutting that thing
tight to fucking take it out of the belly of a plane.
Five hours later in a desert climate.
Can't have that.
Can't have that on a fucking level.
Um,
all right,
so that's the,
uh,
that's the Thursday afternoon podcast.
I hope I gave you some chuckles.
I want to thank everybody that came out in mobile,
Alabama and Jackson.
Mississippi was the shit was the shit.
That's such a good time there.
And,
um,
I really enjoyed the city,
but from what I saw,
we kind of rolled in.
I didn't see too much of it,
but um,
you know,
obviously,
there's still flying the confederate flag underneath the American flag at the,
uh,
the State House,
which is a hell of a thing to say.
But,
um,
you know,
everybody I met down there was nice,
I had a good time
and everybody fucking hung out afterwards.
That by in the posters,
I'm coming out,
I'm making the people,
I'm shaking the hands and uh,
I'll tell you,
underrate it.
Mobile Alabama man didn't nice.
If you can't afford to fly somewhere and you just want to jump in your car and
go hang out in a cool city that's got a bunch of great places to drink.
And,
uh,
oh,
by the way,
apologies accepted for that crazy lady went to this place and we were shooting
pool and um,
this lady was just,
you know,
she was that level drunk that as she was walking up to talk to me,
her friends were already apologizing for.
And uh,
you know,
so I took a picture,
we did the whole fucking thing,
and then it was finally like,
all right,
bait it,
paid it,
and then of course she's getting mad and then she's yelling at me going,
you know,
I used to be your fan now at all.
Like you.
Yeah,
so fuck you and fuck you.
You fuck up.
Fuck Great.
You know,
saying that I was a jerk and I just yelled over,
I just said,
you're blaming the victim.
Go sober.
Roppe tomorrow.
Do you have any sort of a human being?
You're all apologize,
you know,
when did you know she did it?
What a good shit,
right?
We've all been there.
We've all get boost up and said something.
We didn't mean to say.
All right,
well he did for a kiss that wasn't there.
We've all done it.
All righty.
That's it.
I hope you guys have a wonderful weekend.
This is all positive billion.
Thursday.
Hope you have a wonderful weekend.
Hit The fucking gym for very least eat right.
You know,
don't eat yourself into a bad situation.
Summer's coming up.
You want to walk down the beach showing off the guns,
Huh?
Or maybe a fucking yeah,
either way.
Get after it.
Have a great weekend,
Eh,
uh,
that's it.
Alright.
Ended normally.
Tell you to go fuck yourselves and I'm not going to do that.
Have a wonderful weekend
and enjoy these clips from a year's gone by.
MMM.
Friend of mine who actually runs the,
uh,
the m m podcast page,
the,
uh,
the fan page,
the official and only fan page or the Monday morning podcast,
um,
who he gets exclusive,
uh,
whatever.
You know,
what I do is I do the podcast now cause I want,
I want,
I want to take this podcast and next level is what I do is I do the podcast then
I,
you know,
I upload it and I sent it to the dude who runs that page and he puts all the
fucking,
you know,
all the references up,
all the youtube videos and everything.
Then we try to sync it where we both fucking put it on at the same time,
you know,
taking it to the next level.
Totally lost.
Just lost my fucking train of thought here.
Um,
oh,
that's right.
He sent me this article.
This is the classic just dumbing down,
okay.
Just pussy way that we're running this country right now.
These,
there's peak people actually I guess the,
uh,
the nationwide,
the national spelling bee is coming up,
you know,
and everybody laughs at these,
these kids who go up there,
they're right at their fucking awkward years.
You know what I mean?
Where they have the nose of the adult and like the fucking teeth of a fucking
two year old,
you know,
12 year old.
So,
um,
they have in the national spelling bee and Washington DC,
they celebrate these uh,
these brainiac fucking kids that eventually will work for a corporation and
without really knowing it will probably work on some device,
settle Sunday,
kill millions of people,
you know,
in other words,
the future.
So there's people actually they're picketing the spelling bee.
All right.
I had to,
I had to fucking read this to actually believe it.
Okay.
It says not all spellers headed for Washington DC for the National Spelling Bee
spelling bee on June 1st through the third think English spelling is a good
thing that should be celebrated with spectators and judges inside the Grand
Hyatt Hotel.
Uh Oh wow.
While spectators and judges inside the Grand Hyatt Hotel will be pondering the
spellings of obscure words and admiring the efforts of contestants outside on
the streets.
Some members of the American Literacy Council and These Simplified Spelling
Society,
Aka the s s.
S we'll be trying to convince Passerbuys that the English spelling is a problem
that needs fixing.
Okay.
Why are people so fucking dumb?
And then that's something.
If you want to get support,
simplified spelling society,
you don't go to the fucking nationwide spelling bee where the the kids just
learned,
okay,
how to spell fucking rheumatoid arthritis.
So whatever the fuck they going to ask them,
can you use it in a sentence?
Your grandmother has rheumatoid arthritis.
Okay.
That was me really tight.
I tried it.
Isn't that two words?
Um,
why don't you just go to a bar?
Yeah.
You want to get names on that fucking petition.
That's who you're doing it for.
The dumb fucks.
This is the point these people have it said like those in size side.
They may admire the efforts of the contestants,
but they will have signs and sandwich boards with slogans such as I'm through
with,
through,
in other words,
I'm through with,
through and enough is enough spelled e,
u,F ,
and enough is too much spelled e.
Their aim is to alert parents,
educators,
politicians,
business people,
and others concerned about the unacceptable level of illiteracy,
illiteracy among English speakers to the fact that a prime cause for this is
English spelling.
Do you get it?
The reason why there's such a high level of illiteracy is not because we
constantly cut funding to the public schools,
not because spelling is something that's even fucking stressed by most people
anymore.
It's because the words are too difficult to spell.
One of the pickers pickers,
one of the picketers.
This is hilarious and I can't even fucking read.
I'm part of the problem.
I might sign these people's petition.
Um,
one of the picketers at the ALC chair and the SSS member,
Allen Mole from Boulder,
Colorado,
put it this way,
are odd spelling retains words like cough bowl through and though this increases
illiteracy and crime fix it and you fix a host of problems,
we want to fix it to this guy is basically saying,
yeah,
that the reason why there's serial killers,
there's people holding up fucking Mcdonald's,
there's purse snatchers
and all this type of shit is because cat is not spelled with a k.
Yeah,
I mean on one side I fucking respect this guy because he's actually has a cause.
He actually got off his couch and said,
you know what?
I'm going to do something about this.
This is the reverse of what I was trying.
Maybe that's why.
Let's get smart America bombed on my podcast.
You know,
you guys are waiting for this sss guy to come in here,
you know,
I mean not,
not to be the classic person who goes,
what's going to happen next,
but what is going to happen next?
Two plus two was like four or five,
three,
you know,
as long as you're within one,
we'll give it to you.
Okay.
Rounded off to the nearest right answer.
Learn how to fucking spell your lazy fucks as pathetic.
And I also like how to like the illiteracy illiteracy problem is,
you know,
that's the reason why there's fucking crime.
You know?
I bet those fucking bankers,
you know,
those bankers are literate and they're great at math.
They're great if fucking math where it always works out for them.
The fucking concert,
they went till fucking Ivy League schools.
Why did I,
why did I take her off?
I really schools,
Ivy League schools.
They went to Ivy League fucking schools and went to Brown.
They went to Cornell.
Yeah.
Wentworth.
I Dunno,
that's one for you that are just some party fucking uh,
you know,
something that's,
you know what killed it?
What killed it was a was cable.
That's what,
that's what,
that's what really made people dump cable and the Internet.
800 fucking channels.
You know,
people used to back in the day,
they used to load up as something called a station wagon.
All right?
First of all,
everybody had like five fucking kids back in the day.
All right.
Which was a great thing to do.
You know,
cause you know a couple of them are going to be fuck ups.
Okay.
And you can let it go.
You can let it go.
That's why parents who have only one kid is so fucking over protective
protective is because they went all in world series of poker.
They pushed all the chips and this is their one fucking hope.
That kid can't be a fucking serial killer.
You have seven,
eight fucking kids,
you know one of them,
you know
you can handle it.
You can fucking handle it.
If one of them's a phase,
the black sheep,
what are you going to dope?
Okay.
You know,
what the fuck are you going to do?
I mean the guy,
he's a
transvestite and sometimes pyromaniac.
Huh?
Anybody remember that line there?
He met a transvestite and sometimes pyromaniac the greatest line ever uttered on
the fucking a and e channel.
Possibly in television history when they were talking about these ds,
this,
this serial killer tandem.
That's how they described one of the guys.
One of the guys was just killing somebody on his own and then he had to leave
town.
Okay.
Because the heat was getting too high and you went to a new town,
hangs out in some shady bar and that's where he meets his,
his,
his serial killer partner.
You know,
Kinda like when Bill Gates met that other fucking nerd and they made the first
laptop,
these two serial killers came together
and to describe his partner that the fucking,
that Bill Curtis guy goes there.
He met a transvestite and sometimes pyromaniac
back in the day people we had station wagons and there was a whole bunch of
fucking kid.
He didn't have to have a fucking spelling bee.
Okay,
you have a spelling bee because you only have one kid and the kid can't compete
against himself.
You've got to go with a bunch of other fucking kids.
Back in the day we had station wagons and they were full of fucking kids.
All right.
And you just,
you drove somewhere and on the way there,
you know,
you listen to Mitch Miller.
Okay,
bullies,
Ooh,
we'll room
right
and you're fucking,
you said Shit like,
um,
do you get any,
do your parents would quiz you?
What are Ivy League schools named?
The capitols of states.
Okay.
You know,
that's what the fuck you did and you stopped at a rest area.
Your Dad sent you in there by yourself.
There was no problem,
there was no worries.
And you walked in there
and some guy exposes himself to you.
It is not a deal with it.
It just buried it.
You got back in the fucking car and next thing you know you're at a dairy queen.
Sort of enjoying the ice cream,
but sorta not.
That's when America was intelligent.
Back when we used to have like five,
six kids and you throw him in a fucking station wagon and then you quizzed him
as you drove to some poor excuse for a tourist attraction.
You know,
you go out to go look at fucking while bill Cody's fucking log cabin.
You know your dad be sitting there seething with anger,
left arm,
all sunburned from having it hanging out the side fucking window.
The rest of them ghost white
and that was it.
Spelling tests,
quizzes and dairy queen.
Somewhere along the line it became OMG laughing my fucking ass off all this
abbreviation.
These people want to turn it into that.
Fuck that man up.
You pussies learn how to spell goddamn words.
I did it for a month.
I'm a better speller because it because of it because it I'm not,
I've already forgot.
I finally conquered the word restaurant though forever.
I couldn't remember where the you went.
It's rest and then a u.
R.
A.
N.
T.
I could never remember if the you came,
which,
which a the you came after.
Is it restaurant or restaurant?
Restaurant.
It's a restaurant.
These fucking people would spell an r.
T restaurant now.
No,
that was still be fucked up.
How do you spell rant?
Dose,
you know that's restaurant.
How do I spell that?
Phonetically?
R E s t.
T restaurant,
go to the fucking restaurant.
I look,
I'm getting so worked up like these guys are actually going to succeed.
Um,
you know,
and he's like,
listen to people down the south when they talk about the South Gilder rise
again.
Is it,
are you going to secede from the union?
How did that work out the first time?
Wow.
What do you mean.